wearing one suit everywhere you go does
not count as drip everyone looks good
suit's gone everyone everyone looks good
in a [ __ ] everyone looks good in the
suit not no no they don't no they don't
bro no they don't you'd have to do
something like really really bad to [ __ ]
up looking good in the suit yeah you
could you could do it you do it now
let me think about that
look bad in general i guess
just be really ugly just get a bad
fitting suit but uh if
yeah or your dad's suit that's pretty
much the union yeah yeah yeah where did
that suit but if it's fitted then
everyone looks good yeah
i guess
[Music]
i don't want to concede this point right
because i'm then i'm i'm i'm
thinking by this point because i can't
remember someone did like someone did
like an annie tuba drip tier list or
something oh yeah um i can't remember
who it was i remember you were like moon
did one right i i don't i don't think it
was moody because whoever whoever this
person
one whoever this is was yeah like put
conor in like s tier and i'm just like
conor does not deserve to go and [ __ ]
sto drip he just wears one [ __ ] jojo
soon cause he's everywhere
everyone is blinded by the jojo suit
that is not drip
if everyone had a jojo suit everyone
would be an st well then everyone should
get a jojo suit joe
that's not drip just waiting i want to
start a charity service to give everyone
a jojo suit to move you down the drip
tier
that's how much i care about this [ __ ]
i'm going to come back in a few weeks
with more drafts i saw that serious
video and when they put connor on s2
because of the jojo suit i'm like this
man literally isn't an st we're wearing
an emu like shirt i'm like
how the [ __ ] i'm gonna say you're gonna
tell me the same [ __ ] emmy shirt that
he wears on like every other week of
trash taste puts him in st right now
that is i'm i'm leaving i'm like i got a
[ __ ] beat here compared
but i worked for my [ __ ] like i actually
have like a wardrobe full of [ __ ] and i
get beaten by one jojo suit which i also
have which we all [ __ ] own you should
get we should get five then shouldn't we
and then we'll talk
you have one jojo suit i have five we
are not the same standard is so loyal
that's what i learned
because it's because you know i'm not
normally salty but i'm that day i was
sorted out
this is my confirmation that weebs do
not have drip yeah
every time i post pictures in the jojo
soup the perfect soup factory the maker
of the soup posts it to their instagram
i couldn't believe it at least twice
they've done it and i was like oh okay
cheers they're like look look this is
drip yeah see the makers of the suit
agree i i should be i am i am dripping i
don't think they're both they made
don't think they've been reposting it
because they think it's drip i think
they're reposting it because they
[ __ ] made it no no no they're
reposting because they're like [ __ ] man
they're like this post got viral yeah
we might wear daiso socks and put it up
on an instagram post i'm sure daiso
would read it
and they won't say this is drip they'll
say
thank you for buying a [ __ ] 100 game
sauce all right let's see it let's watch
it happen then joey all right
well no i'm not going to because i don't
why not no no no no no
we should buy you a pair [ __ ] daiso
socks it's all about the family it's all
about the it's all about the [ __ ]
family are you wearing it now it's all
about the family mart's songs
we talked about this before i don't know
so joey came to me one day and they were
like have you worn family socks before i
found family mart socks which is a
comedian store obviously in japan
no why would i wear family family mart
socks because they're amazing and then
they were like the most comfortable
socks on earth and i was like all right
okay so one of my one of my gaijin
friends living here like told me about
this like revelation being like have you
heard he came to me like [ __ ]
jehovah's witnesses like have you heard
of the family master socks it's like no
please do tell me and they're like yeah
they're really they're like i think like
400 yen three four it's like three four
bucks right for a pair of socks and i
was like
how how good could a four dollar pair of
socks be at a convenience store of all
places yeah wore it
felt like i was floating bro
literally and then i was like i have to
tell i was like
yeah yeah yeah
you got you go you gotta turn into like
a jehovah's witness
he starts preaching to me about this i
was around his house right i was around
his house i was playing mahjong and he
starts preaching to me i'm just like
it's just just [ __ ] socks joey yeah
aki comes back with like five pairs of
socks and goes yeah i'll give you one
for free i'm like i don't need this it's
a pair of literally the guy giving the
bible just give it a go
what am i going to do with this and
i remember
i i got home and i put it put it in the
way in the corner and i remember we had
a trash taste recording the other day
and i hadn't done my washing the day
before and so i opened my drawer empty
sock drawer except for the one family
mask sock and they always it was just it
was just staring me in the face and i'm
just like
oh fine i'll wear the family mart socks
and like um this this one scene from
rick and morty where rick uh where rick
gives morty like the perfectly flat
piece of land right do you remember that
scene i think so i can't remember where
where it's like perfectly flat and
morty's like oh what is this all it's
just perfectly fine he steps on it and
he literally starts coming right
and i was just like
i was like oh it's just [ __ ] socks
how could this cow how good could this
be and i put it on and i'm just like
oh
it fits so snuggly
it's it's hugging my feet what is what
is this feeling it's what is this cotton
it's so soft
it's like it's like i'm walking on sheep
right now what is this and i answer and
i text joey i'm just like
[ __ ] you
i have done it i have converted it i
don't know why it feels so smooth and so
silky smooth on your skin i can't wear
any other
it feels like a thousand kisses on your
feet my my favorite pair of socks from
yeah i bought two years ago yeah yeah
it's from lawson's
i'm telling you they do a black pair of
socks and they are like the cleanest
socks i own are they as good as the
family master i think they're better i
doubt i you've got to try it
out i bought these socks right for two
years i've been washing them
with the family mark gospel right now
they have not they have not lost their
like firmness they haven't worn out at
all you know sometimes you get socks
they go crinkly and they go hard after a
while when you wash them because they've
been used so much these socks [ __ ]
warriors bro they're like day one they
look no different these socks are
amazing not me mad brother he's just
lost this way he's lost his way we will
guide him to the right direction you
guys give me a pair of family i'll give
you guys a pair of the lawson's black
okay you'll see
a trash taste uh sock trunk
you'll see you'll see these socks
it's it's so insane because i remember
walking into our family marts uh in
tokyo the other day and they literally
had a table just for the family mart
socks by themselves which just shows how
far the gospel spreads yeah that they've
like literally got a table front and
center in the combinations
yeah that's because they're probably
always sold out yeah like every i think
i've been to about four or five
different family mods after i first
tried the socks i was like i have to get
more so i was like scouting around tokyo
i swear for the first four or five
family markets they're all sold out i'm
curious what made you buy them in the
first place it's it's just like a thing
that started with like gaijins living in
japan about like like one yeah one of
the foreigners that was living here like
posted on twitter about
like trying out these family my socks
and then it kind of just spread like
wildfire from yeah and then it made its
way to me yeah it's the it's the socks
and the pumpkin spice latte yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah what was
pumpkin spice latte got to do with this
starbucks
oh because pumpkin spice lattes in spa
pumpkin spice latte has only just now
become really massive in japan because
of the gaijin
and i guess the same thing happened with
the family mod socks and so everyone was
like all right i mean it's only four
bucks i'll try it out yeah and then the
gospel spread
and i'm like this is i'm pretty sure
this is how religion stuck
through socks
one person says it's good and then the
rest follows
religion